انفراجه في ملف المساعدات العسكريه ثقيله
لاوكرانيا برلين تمنع وصول لبارد لكير
ايران انترناشونال تكشف عن مشروع للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا يستنفذ خزينه طهران وينفذه
فيلق القدس
بعد العثور على جثه القاتل بايدينيا مر
بتنكيس الاعلام حدادا على ضحايا مجزره
كاليفورنيا
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير اهلا بكم الى
فتره اخباريه جديده من العربيه
ستتخذ قرارا قريبا بشان تزويد اوكرانيا
بير بوك ان بلادها لن تقف في طريق بولندا
اذا ارسلت الاخيره
دون موافقه المانيا فلن تقف في الطريق
وقبل ذلك استقبل رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون المستشار الالماني او للشلتز في
باريس لاحياء ذكرى 60 لمعاهده التي ارسلت
المصالحه بين البلدين مكروه اكد ان باريس
لا تستبعد تسليما دبابات ليوكير القتاليه
ثقيله لاوكرانيا لدعمها في الحرب ضد روسيا
لم يتعهد الرئيس الفرنسي بارسال دبابات
لكلر القتاليه الشهيره الى اوكرانيا لكنه
لم يستبعد ذلك وشكل ما قاله تطورا نسبيا
في موقف باريس تحدث عن معايير محدده
ستراعى في حال ارسال هذه الدبابات
الا تكون الخطوه تصعيديه وان تؤمن هذه
الدبابات دعما حقيقيا وفعليا لاصدقائنا
الاوكرانيين
اما المستشار الالماني الذي توقع ان تستمر
الحرب في اوكرانيا لفتره طويله جدا فقد
بقي جوابه غامضا بشان احتمال
اثنين نحن خلال عقود لم نقدم سلاحا للدول
التي تعيش النزاعات من دون نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لكننا غيرنا سياستنا
بالتنسيق خصوصا مع امريكا وفرنسا ودول
اوروبيه اخرى
تحدث لنا عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
والدفاع في مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي جيل
بالرجاء عن ضروره ارسال دبابات قتاليه
لحمايه اوكرانيا ومن خلفها كل اوروبا
مسيرات الايرانيه وارسال الدبابات قادره
على التحرك سريع
جاء سلبيان الختامي والاعلان المشترك
الفرنسي الالماني ان البلدين حريصا على
شراكه اطلسيه قويه كلام يعكس تقارب
اللفظيا بين باريس وبرلين فيما الخلافات
حول قضايا الدفاع والطاقه ما زالت كامله
براي مراقبين الازمه الصامته بين قطبي
الاتحاد الاوروبي الرئيسيين تمحورت اولا
حول تباين حاجتين الى الغاز الروسي وثانيا
حول عدم وجود رؤيه دفاعيه اوروبيه مشتركه
ذهبت برلين بعيدا عن باريس اولا نحو الصين
ثم نحو الولايات المتحده ودول اخرى في حلف
النيته وكاد تتعاون حتى مع اسرائيل حول
منظومه صاروخيه حذر نكره المانيا من ان
تعزيل نفسها اوروبيه فتراجعت في الشكل
واللهجه على الاقل حسين قنيبر العربيه من
قصر الاليزيه باريس
حظه مشارعون امريكيون اداره رئيس وبيضن
على تصدير الدبابات ابرامز القتاليه الى
اوكرانيا قائلين ان ارسال عدد رمزي منها
سيكون كافيا لتشجيع الحلفاء الاوروبيين
على فعل نفس الامر وقال مايكل ما قال عضو
الحزب الجمهوري للجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
بمجلس النواب ان دبابه واحده فحسب من
دبابات ابرامز ستكون كافيه لتشجيع الحلفاء
وخصوص المانيا على ارسال دبابات دعما
لاوكرانيا في قتالها ضد روسيا اما سنه
راديمقراطيه كريستانس فقال انه انا الاوان
لتنحيه المخاوف جانبا ومواصله العمل مع
حلفائنا المقربين والمضي قدما في تزويد
كياب بالدبابات
هذا هو تصاعد الحديث عن تزويج اوكرانيا
بالدبابات في الاونه الاخيره لكن كيف يمكن
لكيف ان تتمسك بدبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه
اكثر من تماسكها بدبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
او غيرها لماذا الاجابه نتبعها مع زميلها
ليال
خيبه امل الاوكرانيه بعد ما فشلت الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه باقناع برلين لارسال دبابات
ليوبار اليها رغم الضغوط الدوليه الداخليه
ولكن لماذا تتمسك اوكرانيا بدبابات
اليوبار الالمانيه اكثر من ابرامز
الامريكيه هذه الدبابات مشاهدينا تعد
الاقوى في العالم بعد ابرامز الامريكيه
تشغيلها وصيانتها اسال بكثير من الدبابات
الامريكيه التي تحتاج الى وقود طائره اما
الدبابات الالمانيه الصنع فتحتاج الى
الديزل لتشغلها
وتقتصد اكثر في المصروف نتحدثنا عن الطاقه
من الدبابه الامريكيه وفق الخبراء
العسكريه لا يوبر الالمانيه هي ايضا اخف
وزنا واسرع حركه ويمكنها ان تصيب اهداف
ادق وابعد من ابرز وهذا الامر اشار اليه
واشنطن سابقا عندما قالت ان الصعوبات
التقنيه هو سبب الرئيسي لرفض ارسال واشنطن
لدبابات
دبابات لايوبارت 2 بدا تصنيعها عام 1979
في المانيا الغربيه كدبابات قتال رئيسيه
يمكنها التصدي للدبابات السوفياتيه طبعا
ايام الحرب البارده التقديرات العسكريه
مشاهدينا تشير الى وجود نحو
1150 دبابات ليوبار لدى الدول الاوروبيه
من بينها طبعا المانيا فيما تطالب
اوكرانيا ب100 من هذه الدبابات وتقول انها
ستكون كافيه لردع الهجوم الروسيه وشنها
جمال لاستعاده الاراضي الاكرانيه دول
البلقتين
واستونيا وليتوانيا وجهه دعوه مشتركه الى
المانيا لارسال الدباباتها الرئيسيه الى
اوكرانيا لمساعده اكياس طبعا في حربها ضد
روسيا ولكنها برين تتخوف من رد فعل روسيه
امكانيه ان تعتبر روسيا ارسال هذه
الدبابات الى كاف تصعيدا في الحرب مما يت
طبعا باذى لالمانيا مباشره لقد يعرضها
لانتقام روسيا
في ذات سياقه اعلن نائب وزير خارجيه
الايطاليه ان السلطات الايطاليه والفرنسيه
بصدد استكمال العمل لارسال المنظومه
الدفاع الجوي سم تي الى اوكرانيا
صواريخ جاهزه للاطلاق
مصممه لحمايه ساحه المعركه والمواقع
التكتيكيه الحساسه
تتمتع بقدره تغطيه تبلغ 360 درجه للاكتشاف
والاشتباك
لديها قدرات مواجهه بعض هذه الاهداف على
الارتفاعات الشديده الانخفاض
توفر قدره حقيقيه ضد الصواريخ والطائرات
مخصصه لمواجهه الاهداف في بيئه التشويش
الالكترونيه المعقده
عام 1990 بدات تطوير منظومه سام تي
في 2013 نشر الجيشان الايطالي والفرنسي
منظومه
داخل بنيه حلف الناتو للمره الاولى
التي بلغت 180 الف قتيل وجيري
ونحو 30 الف مدني واضاف رئيس الاركان
الروجيه ان روسيا قادره على مواصله الحرب
لفتره طويله رغم غسائرها الكبيره وتمتلك
قدره على التعبئه العسكريه وانتاج الاسلحه
للاستمرار في الحرب واستخدامي صواريخ
بعيده المدى واوضح رئيس اركان النرويج ان
اوكرانيا بحاجه ماسه للدبابات اذا تعرضت
لهجوم كبير هذا الشتاء للدفاع عن اراضيها
قالت ايران انترناشونال لان النظام
الايراني يوصل انشطته المزعجعه للاستقرار
في المنطقه من خلال الحرس الثوري رغم
مشاكله الداخليه مضيفه انها حصلت على
معلومات قالت انها عن فريق من الحرس
الثوري الايراني لانشاء نظام دفاعيا جوي
في سوريا مما يدل على ان طهران تنفق
ملايين الدولارات من الميزانيه العامه
للدوله في سوريا مجله نيوز ويكي الاخرى
قالت الاسبوع الماضي ان النظام الايراني
انفق عشرات الملايين من الدولارات وارسل
معدات لانشاء شبكه دفاع جوي شامله في
سوريا خلال العامين الماضيين لكن اسرائيل
تهاجم هذا المشروع باستمرار وفي السنوات
الاخيره كانت عناصر الدفاع الجوي
الايرانيه في سوريا تعمل تحت اشراف كبار
المسؤولين في الحرس الثوري الايراني
باشراف جواد غافل الذي طرد من سوريا
الخليفه الماضي والان باشراف محمد رضا
زاهدي احد قاضت فيلقس التابع للحائط
الثوري الايراني
ايرانيا ايضا هددت وزاره الاستخبارات
الايرانيه الاوروبيين باستهداف مصالحهم في
اسيا اذا صنفت الحركه الثوريه تنظيما
الارهابيا وقالت الوزاره انها تمتلك
معلومات سريه بانهاء الاوروبيين للمرحله
الاولى من تصنيف الحركه الثوريه تنظيما
ارهابيه وحذرت وزاره الاستخبارات
الايرانيه الدول الاوروبيه من انها ستقوم
بالرد بالمثل في حال صدر القرار الذي
تعتبره يتعارضوا مع الامن القومي للنظام
الايراني
منذ وفاه محسن اميني في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي بعد ما اعتقلتها شرطه
الاخلاق في تهران تشهد ايران احتجاجات
داميه لا تزال مستمره منذ اشهر
التي اشعلت شراره اطول موجه احتجاجه بدات
بعد اعتقالها على يد الشرطه الاخلاق
ووفاتها في السادس عشر من سبتمبر الماضي
150 مدينه ايرانيه حسب المعارضه على مدار
[موسيقى]
او الى ديسمبر الماضي لاحتواء الاحتجاجات
صدر قرار بحل الشرطه الاخلاق
مصيرا مماثله
العاصمه بروكسل يطالبون بالافراج عن
مواطنهم المعتقل في ايران
وقالت نتيجه نتاليا شقيقه فانديسكيل لانها
تحدثت عائلتها مع اوليفي ويوم الجمعه
الماضي حيث اخبرهم بانه اوقف اضرابه عن
الطعام من اجل الوقايه على قيد الحياه حيث
فقد نحو 25 كلغ من وزنه
قال السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل توم
نايكيز ان بلاده ستعمل مع حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو بشان الملف الايراني وذلك لاهميه
البالغان لامن البلدين على حظ قوله نادز
قال ايضا ان اداره رئيس بيض لن تربط
جهودها حيل ايران باستعداد الجانب
الاسرائيلي للتعاون بشان القضيه
الفلسطينيه الا ان ذلك لن يغير اهتماما
واشنطن الشديد حسب وصفه بالحفاظ على حل
الدولتين السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل اكد
كذلك ان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي يدرك
الرفض الامريكي لاي خطط من شانها ضم اراضي
فلسطينيه جديده الى اسرائيل
ونبقى معكم في سياق هذه النشره ولدينا
التحالف يكذب دعايات الحوثيين حول قصف
منبع وشدى وعمليه امنيه تحبط تهريب طائره
مسيره للميليشيا
نواصل مع حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره امر
رئيس الامريكي جوبيد الاحد بتنكيس الاعلام
الامريكيه في المباني العامه تكريما
لضحايا اطلاق النار الجماعيه في مونتري
بارك بي كاليفورنيا ووجه بيض بخفض الاعمى
الاعلام حتى غروب الشمس في السادس
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري احتراما لضحايا
اعمال العنف التي ارتكبت يوم السبت في
مونتري بارك بولايه كاليفورنيا حزم جاء في
بيان للبيت الابيض
قرار بيدن جاء بعد ان عثرت الشرطه
الامريكيه على جثه داخل سياره كانت
تطاردها خلال بحثها عن مطلق النار في
كاليفورنيا حيث تبين لاحقا انها جثه
الجاني صحيفه لوس انجلوس الامريكيه نشرت
نقلا عن مصدر في الشرطه ان السائقه اطلق
النار على نفسه عقبه مطارده الشرطه لهم من
جاءته اعتبر قائد شرطه لوس انجلوستون
حادثه اطلاق النار احد ابشع القضايا في
المقاطعه واشار لون ان القتلاهم خمسه نساء
وخمسه رجال اضافه الى جرح 10 اشخاص على
الاقل حالته بعضهم حرجه وكشف لون انها
منافذ الهجوم امريكيه من اصل اسيويه ويبلغ
من العمر 72 عاما
امريكيه ايضا ومع استمرار العثور على
وثائق سريه جديده بحوزه رئيس جبيد يفكر
المدعي العام في طلب بتفتيش المنزل ثاني
للرئيس بيدن في ولايه
الرابعه يعصر المسؤولون من وزاره العدل
على وثائق ذات تصنيفا سري في حوزه الرئيس
الامريكي
وثائقه تضيف تحديات غير مسبوقه على
الاداره الحاليه السياسيا وقضائيا خاصه
بظل الحديث عن استمرار عمليات البحث التي
ستشمل منزلا ثانيا للرئيس بعيدا من قبل
مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليمه
الرئيس كان يملك سابقا تصاريح امنيه تسمح
له بالحصول على هذه المستندات وبالتالي
فان حقيقه عدم ارجاعه بعض المستندات لا
يجعلها مساله جنائيه
قضائيا يتم التعامل مع هذه الوثائق من قبل
وزاره العدل على انه تحقيق النرويتيني لان
الرئيس يتعاون بشكل تام ولكن الوزاره
اشارت الى امكانيه تغير طبيعه التحقيق اذا
كشف المدعي العام المسؤول عن مراجعه
الوثائق اي دليل على ان بعد ام موظفين
تعمد تظليل الارشيف الوطني
اذا الرئيس
توقيتا لان الرئيس يتحضر لاعلان ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2420
بين ترامب ايضا موقف وزاره العدل صعب
للغايه في كلتا الحالتين فعاده ما يتم
التعامل مع هذه المواقف اداريا وليس
جنائيا ومعايير المحاكمه الجنائيه تشمل
اثباتا ان الشخص قد انتهك عمدا القواعد
الخاصه بكيفيه تامين المواد ريتا سليمان
العربيه واشنطن
تحالف دعم الشرعيه في اليمن المزاعم
الحوثيه بوجود قصف حدودي على مديريتيما به
وشذى في اليمن واكد تحالف في بيان دعمه
كافه الجهود لتثبيت الهدنه المنتهيه في
اكتوبر الماضي شدد البيان ايضا على ان قوه
التحالف تمارس اعلى درجات ضبط النفس في ظل
استمرار خلقاتهم
هذا واحبطت الاجهزه الامنيه في محافظه
المهره شرق اليمن عمليه تهريب شحنه من
تجهيزات وقطع طائرات بدون طيار تابعه
لمليشيا الحوثي في منفذ شحن الحدوديه
مصادر امنيه افادت ان الشحنه كانت تضم 25
صندوقا موحا تحتوي على نحو مئه محرك خاص
بطائرات بدون طياره وذكرت المصادر
النجاحنه استخدمت وثائقات تشير الى انها
قطع غيار تابعه لشبكه اتصالات بينما كانت
الصناديق تحت شعار هواوي وذلك لتمويه على
حقيقه الشحنه
ومن تقارير هذه نشره يعيش الافغانيون هذا
العام شتاء قارسا لم يعدوه منذ اعوام
طويله حيث توفي العشرات متاثرين ببروده
الطقس وسط ووضع اقتصاديا وانساني يتدهور
يوما بعد يوم
قساوه على الجدران
هذا كله ما تحتمي به العائلات هنا كسوه
للشتاء عرض اجسادهم تلجا العائله الى هذه
الحيله سخونه تنقذ ما خلفته الليالي
البارده الصغار
ههه
بارد جدا هذا العام ولا يمكننا ان نحافظ
على دفئنا بسبب الطقس شديد البروده هذا
الطفل يعاني من الامراض ايضا انه يعاني من
شتاء قاس حقه وليس لديه جوارب ولا احذيه
ارتدائها
منازل بلا اسقف نزحت اليها مئات الاسر
الافغانيه هربا من حركه طالبا اسقطهم مر
اللجوء في بلادهم الى ان استقبلوا الشتاء
الاصعب منذ اعوام شرد وقت المئات حتى الان
سيجاره
وهطول الامطار ولا احد يساعد الاهالي
يعانون من الامراض و يموتون بسبب البرد
القارس
شاهدتم رامات بسبب شده البرد ولم يكن
لدينا المال الكافي لشراء نعش لها
بسبب الشتاء القارس وفقه اخر احصائيات
رسميه ضحايا البرد مرشحون للزياده مع
استمرار انخفاض درجات الحراره ناهيك عن
اوضاع اقتصاديه طالت اساسيات الحياه غذاء
السالم العربي العربيه
كشف تحقيق لجريده الجارديان البريطانيه عن
اختفاء العشرات من الاطفال طالب اللجوء في
بريطانيا بظروف غامضه وسط انباء عن
اختطافهم من قبل عصابات اجراميه
خلال ال 18 شهرا الماضيه عاش حوالي 600
طفل من طالب اللجوء بدون ذويهم في فندق
تديره وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه بمدينه
برايتون
تم الابلاغ عن اختفاء 136 منهم
لا يزال اكثر من نصف هؤلاء بما يعادل 79
طفلا في عداد المفقودين
الجارديان
ربما يتم الاتجار ببعض الاطفال المفقودين
في اماكن بعيده مثل مانشستر واسكتلندا
وزيره الداخليه
على الحكومه البريطانيه الكشف عن عدد
الاطفال الذين اختفوا وما الذي يتم فعله
للعثور عليهم
[موسيقى]
222 من طالبين اللجوء غير المسحوبين
بدويهم فقدوا من الفنادق التي تديرها
وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
ثقيله لاوكرانيا برلين لنت مانع وصول
يوبارد لكيا
ايران انترناشونال تكشف عن مشروع للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا القدس
بعد العصور على جثه القتل بايديني يامر
بتنكيس الاعلام حدادا على ضحايا مجزره
كاليفورنيا
نوصل الخدمه الاخباريه مع حضرتكم بعد قليل
[موسيقى]